evacuees in Port Sudan say they feel a
sense of shock at the sudden spiral into
Civil War
many have lived and worked in Sudan for
decades Sudan is
Sudan is living through a moment of real
terror I'm talking about dead bodies on
the streets we smelled the dead bodies
as we were coming to Khartoum the firing
the shelling Sudan is seriously in a
state of real war
among those leaving Assyrians who fled a
Civil War in their own country and have
now been uprooted again
we are around three to five thousand the
numbers large inside the port and also
along the Cornish people are sleeping on
the ground widows children elderly the
ill everyone
the UN says the scale and speed of
what's unfolding is unprecedented in
Sudan and says the humanitarian crisis
is at Breaking Point
[Music]
Army General Abdel fatah al-burhan has
agreed to extend a faltering ceasefire
for 72 hours to allow civilians to leave
an aid to be delivered
a paramilitary group the rapid support
forces has also agreed to a temporary
truce
hello
but on the ground fighting continues
across the country including in hartum
and its Twin City omdaman
Sudanese who have citizenship or
residency rights in the United States
wait to board a U.S Navy ship
we hope God brings peace to everyone in
Sudan we are Sudanese people residing in
the U.S people should not think that
Sudan has been destroyed no things have
happened but we wish to stay strong
somalis arrived in Mogadishu from Port
Sudan
I am pleased that I have finally arrived
in my country however what we have been
through is unusual and hard to describe
but I am grateful for the opportunity to
survive
but for millions of Sudanese there is
nowhere to go they're trapped by
fighting in a country the UN says is
falling apart Victoria gatenby Al
Jazeera
we've got correspondence right across
developments on this story Ahmed Idris
is standing by for us in a Border Town
in Chad Harry mutasa will join us from
Juba the capital of South Sudan but
first let's speak to hibber Morgan she's
on the ground for us in cartoon Hiba I
see that the un's world food program is
now saying that they're going to restart
operations in Sudan that's got to be
good news right does that mean there's
more stability now perhaps
well it gives you a reflection of the
needs of the people here in the capital
and in neighboring states because tens
of thousands of people have fled from
the capital hartum to neighboring states
like Jazeera in the central part of the
country and River Nile and northern
states in the Northern parts of the
country now many of them are living in
the open they're living in schools set
up by the setup for them by the local
communities and they're lacking basic
necessities food water medications these
are the needs of the people who have
fled from the capital to neighboring
states then that the people who are
stuck in the Border also in desperate
need of assistance many of them say
they've been there for more than a week
and have not seen a single Aid
organization delivering any kind of
assistance for them while they wait to
cross the border into Egypt same
situation in the eastern border with
Ethiopia thousands of people stuck
waiting for uh for for the chance to
cross the border into Ethiopia for
safety but also lacking basic
necessities and food and water and
medication like the rest of the people
who fled so the wfp's resumption gives
you an idea of the needs of the people
prior to this conflict between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army 15
million people were in need of
assistance that's a third of Sudan's
population and that number is likely to
increase or probably has increased since
the fighting between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army so Heather
it sounds like wfps operations are going
to be taking place more outside Khartoum
now inside the capital do people feel
like the ceasefire extension is going to
make any difference at all
while people are looking at what's
happening on the ground they're not
monitoring what the rapid support forces
are saying or what the Sudanese Army is
saying they're waiting on a brief lull
and fighting for them to be able to
access shops markets or be able to leave
the capital to neighboring states or
neighboring countries for Refuge people
say that they've seen this repeatedly
over and over again this is the sixth
ceasefire now that's being announced by
both sides but on the ground fighting
continues we were able to hear a loud
explosion around the vicinity of the
presidential Palace just a short while
ago and earlier we spoke to a citizen in
the southern part of the capital heartum
and while we were speaking to her we
were able to hear Heavy Artillery
strikes so people say that they don't
believe the word ceasefire anymore
there's still many people in residential
areas without food and without water and
without running uh without electricity
for days now and they say that this
ceasefires unless they bring back the
operations of Institutions and
Facilities like electricity and water
and banking institutions they don't
think it means much on the ground Heber
Morgan there correspondent on the ground
in Khartoum with all the latest thank
you hibber
well as Heber was just saying in the
capital residents have been describing
just how hard it is to live with little
access to food water or electricity
there is a big problem with safety we
hear the sounds of artillery from the
side it falls in the street in front of
us all the one behind we have to sleep
on the floor there's no water or
electricity there's no food most shops
are closed and the ones which are open
sell products at very high prices we
hardly eat enough we only eat one meal
per day so that the little Food Supplies
we have are enough
but now some who already fled the
capital are actually returning home as
conditions are often even worse
elsewhere
the reason why we left is due to food
shortages grocery stores are closed
pharmacies are closed you live in a
reality where you're not scared of the
gunshots but worried about leaving home
to find nothing no bread nothing
after we spent two days in al-mamura
District we had an idea to move in a
group to madani thinking that housing is
available
we discovered that we live in an area
where electricity is cut off for 15
hours the situation is very difficult
and rent is too expensive many people
felt that they went from a bad situation
to a worse one yes there is war in
cartoon it is a Pity to leave and face
all these hardships but it's better to
face them at home
earlier we spoke to Sally mudawi whose
relatives are in Port Sudan struggling
to make it back to the UK
have a three-year-old cousin who's
British national she's with her mum
who's Sudanese National they're refusing
to let them on the plane she's severely
sick she's supposed to have a
tonsillitis surgery due to it getting
infected but of course with the boy got
canceled she's been in agony screaming
since yesterday so she has to get on
this plane and they're saying at first
they told her that she could go on her
own but the mum cannot go because she
doesn't have a Visa which is absolutely
ridiculous this is a life or death
situation if an infection spreads
through your body and you get sepsis you
will die so are they willing to let a
three-year-old child die at the border
because the mum doesn't have a Visa the
whole family has a British passport
except for the mum and I think that's
absolutely heartbreaking where is the
humanity in this she's sick she's three
years old and she obviously needs her
mom who she's she's dependent on
she's been in agony shivering and
screaming since yesterday she's a child
other than the crisis helpline where we
haven't really had much you know contact
we haven't had any numbers suggested to
us the community the Sudanese Community
has had to come together and share
resources and some people like Mia has
helped me get on Al Jazeera right now
she's been the only person that kind of
could take us through the law and all
all the rights the eligibilities for a
British person is that the spouse or
children are allowed to come with them
but when it's a child with a parent it
doesn't it doesn't apply which doesn't
make sense
all the fighting in Sudan is also
disrupting the flow of goods to
neighboring countries and Chad food
prices are going up well for more on
that let's speak to Ahmed Idris he's in
Audrey that's in Chad near the border
with Sudan Ahmed as we've been saying
for days now people are still arriving
there what sort of stories are you
hearing from them
harrowing experiences by the way and
these numbers keep increasing daily the
world food program in particular says
it's budgeted or is estimated to feed at
least 20 000 people but so far we've
visited a few camps you're talking about
those numbers that are close to that
figure 20 000 people and that is even
because some borders close to this part
of Eastern chart are still inaccessible
by people trying to flee the fighting
especially in the west devil region
they're talking about violence in those
areas homes being destroyed and burned
military outposts been deserted and then
of course the threat of violence being
practical and physical there with ethnic
militias trying to enforce certain rules
and also attacking communities or people
who are not from their own ethnic plans
so basically that's what is happening on
the ground and when you cross the border
into child the country patients here I
really really bad most people if not all
the refugees who crossed over are living
out there in the open under trees and
when you talk to them there are four
things they talk to you about they lack
shelter they like food they like
medicines and they like water that's the
conditions they are in now and because
of the amount of people coming in and
the borders are closed to through the
eastern part of child things are getting
more and more expensive by the day our
supplies run out
Adam Ibrahim dab has come to Audrey
Market to buy groceries only to discover
he can't afford many of them
now he says his family must adjust
previously we could afford three to four
meals a day not anymore eating twice a
day these days is difficult because food
has become so expensive
the village of address is an important
trading point but the fighting across
the border in Sudan has changed
everything for many people here
while there has been a steady stream of
refugees at this Crossing Point into
Eastern chart the flow of goods have
been severely disrupted fighting has
almost cut off this side of landlocked
child from sudanesports that Supply many
of the Imports it needs
his Refugee and Trader who brought his
talk with him he explains why things can
only get worse in the coming weeks
the prices have gone up because
airstrikes hit our main Goods Depot in
Khartoum the road is closed so
transporting any Goods is very difficult
anyone with stock will now try to sell
at a higher price
Market vendors struggled to find buyers
for items that only a few can afford
business is slow but we're grateful
local authorities say prices especially
food items have risen by up to 70 in a
matter of weeks
and that the government is looking for
Solutions planning to subsidize some
Goods
it's an additional burden on a country
where millions of people are already
struggling to put food on the table
the United Nations children fund UNICEF
is saying that the cases of malnutrition
is are beginning to rise in this area
this is of course an area that is prone
to farming uh food shortages and food
insecurity generally and the situation
in the neighboring part of uh in the
neighboring areas of Southwest sorry
Western Darfur area we keep seeing more
and more people coming in for example
yesterday inside
Audrey we've seen 50 Sudanese arrive
along with 20 Indians and these were
lucky people or earlier the people we've
spoken to have escaped the violence in
Western therefore especially in the town
of
um in the town of Janine they're talking
about difficulty negotiating Passage
through a short distance to get to this
side of Chad simply because the ethnic
militias have set abroad blocks and when
you negotiate one ethnic militia you
have to go to another for example one
individual told us that he had to
negotiate for days to access only 500
meters to get into child that's the
situation there and because the violence
still continues in that area remember
Western Depot has seen a lot of violence
over the last 20 years because the
violence continues there there is that
uncertainty as to what is going to
happen as a result people are just
leaving that area trying to come to this
side and when they can't they move
farther towards kaftum and other cities
inside Sudan while the fighting is now
even worse so that's the situation on
that part of the borders indeed joining
the tens of thousands on the Move Ahmed
Idris there our correspondent on the
ground near the Chad Sudan border
talking us through conditions thank you
so much Ahmed well let's get an idea of
the situation now in neighboring South
Sudan and bring in our correspondent
Haru mutasa she's there in the capital
Juba for us Haru I understand people are
heading across the border there too some
of them refugees others returning home
the influx of people coming into South
Sudan is putting a lot of pressure on
limited resources here this country has
its own crisis there is violence in
other parts in some parts of the country
eight agencies says well they're trying
to cope with simply is it enough money
to help anyone everyone so basically
what local businesses are doing is that
they are going around shop to shop
collecting items like food and medicines
these supplies are then sent to the
airports they put on to cargo planes and
flown to the border with Sudan where
thousands of people are waiting to cross
and those supplies are meant to help
them and to be able to cross into South
Sudan South Sudan has a strong
relationship with Sudan this used to be
one country it broke away in 2011 again
independence from Sudan but the two
countries are still very much linked and
president salvakia the leader of South
Sudan has been saying that because of
his influence and close ties with
warring factions in Sudan he's been
talking to them daily on the phone
trying to get them to come here to Juba
told face-to-face talks trying to
resolve the crisis in Sudan but until
that happens and if that happens the
concern of course is the people who are
trying to make their way into South
stand thousands of them stuck along the
border points along the border with
Hotel Sudan they need food that in water
they didn't shout to they need transport
to get away with their going most of
them are from South to down so they have
family and friends in the country others
who don't who end up probably in the
camps for displaced people that are
scattered all across the country it's a
huge humanitarian crisis in a country
with limited resources
Haru mutasa there with all the letters
for us from the south Sudanese capital
thank you so much Harry